retail sales a measure of purchases at
stores restaurants and online increased
in May by seventeen point seven percent
from a month earlier a positive sign as
the economy looks to bounce back from
coronavirus lock downs this type of
spending is a big deal although it makes
up a relatively small portion of GDP
it's an important driver of economic
growth because retail sales affect more
than just retailers they create a ripple
effect throughout the economy
that's why analysts and economists are
paying close attention to this monthly
indicator as a way to gauge whether the
economy at large is recovering here's
how the retail spending ripple effect
works when consumers spend it stores
their stores order more merchandise
which means manufacturers produce more
and order more raw materials so when
consumers open their wallets the economy
tends to run smoother and this type of
spending adds up retail sales have been
growing for decades except for a short
dip around the last recession between
1992 and 2018 retail sales have almost
tripled from 1.8 trillion dollars to 5.3
trillion this includes auto sales sales
at clothing retailers in general
merchandisers like department stores
food and beverage sales and e-commerce
during the pandemic some of these
categories have struggled more than
others auto sales declined sharply as
lockdown swept across the country in
March and April
the biggest component retail sales is
spending on new cars and also spending
on gasoline
now those two categories have been
really hard hit in the corona virus
pandemic because people are not
commuting so they're not spending on gas
and also because there's been so much
fluctuation in the labor market people
are sort of less inclined to buy a new
car because they might not necessarily
be sure if they're gonna have a job next
month
many brick-and-mortar clothing retailers
and department stores saw sales all but
disappeared during coronavirus lockdowns
in April spending on clothing was down
nearly 90 percent from the previous year
Neiman Marcus JC Penney and j.crew which
were all under pressure before the
pandemic
it have recently filed for bankruptcy
well the corona virus pandemic took a
huge hit on retail sales purely because
people were stuck at home you know they
had to stay in their houses due to the
due to the spread of the virus so really
the only areas that we saw much spending
were on food sales for food and
beverages haven't been as deeply
impacted while spending at bars and
restaurants has gone down
people have been stocking up at grocery
stores bending at bars and restaurants
has been hit really hard I mean a lot of
places did manage to continue to provide
take out and curbside deliver and so on
but what we did see was a big bump in
March when people were stocking up you
know they really wanted to fill their
shelves in preparation for their
shutdowns spending online however has
accelerated consumers increased online
purchases in May from the same period
last year by almost 31% well every month
that there's some that you know that the
current virus has been going on we've
seen a greater share of retail sales at
non store retail it's like for instance
amazon.com many people the only option
they have to to buy certain products is
to go online and to spend online more
recently there have been signs that
retail might be recovering the retail
sector lost almost 2.3 million jobs in
April but added nearly 370 thousand back
in May and the hope is that that will
continue as people kind of start to get
out and about and to recover and to
spend more money after after the
shutdowns are over essentially the last
phase of the recovery will be people
going back you know into stores into
malls into enclosed spaces and feeling
comfortable
how confident consumers feel about going
out and spending money safely will help
determine how quickly retail sales might
improve and ripple around the economy